I was going through Instagram the other day and there was this one person who
was talking about the purpose of life and when you die,
what's going to happen?
And uh,
I immediately just started laughing.
I'm like,
you don't know how he's saying this.
Like when you die,
what happens?
And he was like,
when,
um,
spiritual type characters,
just kind of a huckster is a lot of spiritual hucksters out there these days.
There are,
yes.
The,
in the 90s we debunked all of those.
The psychics talking to the dead.
That was,
uh,
that,
that hasn't been too popular in recent years.
But that was a big thing.
People caught onto that little earpiece thing.
The earpiece or just the cold reading.
I see a father figure as this a grandfather,
father,
uncle,
friend of the family,
you know,
you can and he's saying something about,
um,
you know,
it's okay for you to forgive yourself.
Oh,
okay.
Like,
well where was the,
will he hid his will somewhere?
Where is that?
Cause that's what we want to know is you know that that ring he had.
Whereas if you're just vague enough,
I mean like a horoscopes,
if you're just vague enough,
people are like,
oh my God,
it's right all the time.
It's always right.
Like that's not even a real horoscope.
If you really want to pay attention to actual astrology that you,
they have to know the date you were born,
that time you were born.
It's not just the month of August.
You know,
it's like they got a,
they want to know morning or evening.
We think about all that stuff.
It's all bunk.
It,
yeah.
Yeah,
Why has it been around so long?
Uh,
well because the,
well it's called a Barnum effect where,
you know,
PT Barnum you just offer something for everybody.
So if you make it general enough,
you know,
I,
I sent you are an intelligent,
wise person that people really enjoy your company and,
and you like going to parties and be with other people and yet you liked the
quiet solitude of a walk on the beach.
You know when people go on.
Yep.
That is so me,
I've pretty much described every scenario.
You can have your alone,
you're with people.
But it's one of those things where if you talk to someone who is an actual
believer in astrology,
like they,
they are so convinced.
I got a friend of mine who was trying to tell me that he makes all of his
decisions based on consulting with his astrologer.
Well,
Reagan,
Nancy Reagan for his travel after he was shot,
she got real paranoid about that.
Well,
so part of the problem is the astrologers and psychics are themselves
remembering their hits and forgetting their misses,
the confirmation mining.
So I knew a psychic or a magician who was working the psychic friends network,
um,
it back in the 90s when it's hard,
it's hard to make a living as a magician doing kids' parties.
They all want to have their own Vegas show.
But only a few people get that.
So you got to do something on the side.
So this guy was doing psychic friends network and uh,
he told me all about it.
They gave him a book,
a three ring binder,
and you know,
here's the kinds of things you should say.
And you know,
people are calling for love,
health,
money,
career questions.
So you can spend 2030 minutes at 385 a minute just going through there.
You know,
I sent you in a relationship right now and one of these more committed than the
other.
Tell me about that.
10 minutes later,
you know,
they're still talking and you're thinking about travel,
you're not happy with your job.
There's some financial stress in your life right now.
And a,
and then he told me about stuff like now go get a crystal and then a candle.
I want you to set it up here on your desk.
And this would go on and on for hours.
And they charge by the hour and they charge by the hour.
So one of the problems that psychic friend networks had was people were not
paying their phone bills because they,
you know,
come back on $800 phone first and they would just not pay it.
So the phone companies crackdown on the psychic friends network company going,
hey,
this is getting out of hand that people aren't paying their bills.
So they had to ratchet it back a little bit.
This right.
They would do it through the phone.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
They wouldn't get a credit card from you.
They would just stay on the line with you.
Right.
So he told me that when he first started,
he got like 60 cents on the minute,
uh,
for the three 95 at that per minute.
But then they bumped it up as he got more experience and kept him on the line
longer.
They give them bonuses.
Now you get a dollar per minute.
And whenever I'm not illegal,
I mean he's not even a psychic and she didn't,
you have to like,
if you want to be a doctor,
you have to go and you've got to go to medical school.
We've got to get a degree.
It shouldn't.
There's a interesting history there because in New York City for example,
it was difficult to outlaw like the three card Monte guys on the sidewalk with
the cardboard because it's just kind of a game right now.
Now it would be illegal to sell fraudulent stocks or something like that or sell
a product that's advertised as a health product when it's not.
But if say in that case it's under food rather than drugs or say no health
products,
like a vitamin or under different standards than say medical drugs.
I'm a psychic is more like an entertainer.
So this is for entertainment purposes only.
So we can do whatever we want as opposed to a medical doctor that's dispensing
advice.
So
maybe doctors,
a bad example,
maybe I should've said engineer,
but the point is like if you're going to work as a psychic,
like on a psychic network,
if you have a business of selling psychics,
yeah.
Like you should be able to,
you have to exhibit some sort of psychic something.
Well,
they can't,
uh,
you know,
under controlled conditions they always fail.
There's nothing that's ever been done.
No,
no.
What about the one thing that I've read that,
uh,
statistically more people can recognize that people are staring at them?
Yeah.
Like when they're looking at you from behind said Horse Shit.
Well,
it's not been,
it's not been consistently replicated.
Um,
so is it possible that some people with a certain sensitivity can detect?
Well,
we,
okay,
so one explanation,
the skeptics explanation is that if I'm in a,
say a Starbucks or something and I kind of have a sense that people are talking
about may or may be looking at me and,
and,
and I look and that catches somebody's eye and they turned to me and I think,
oh,
that person's looking at me or vice versa.
I'm looking at them and then they send something or whatever.
He said,
there could be some element of chance to that.
Now I'm the guy that does this,
Rupert Sheldrake.
Um,
you know,
he believes that it's actually some kind of like a psychic power through the
medium.
Like when I'm looking at you,
something's coming out of my eyes and tickling in your neck.
So this is morphic resonance,
morphic resonance.
Now,
Richard Wiseman,
a British experimental psychologist,
he's tried to replicate that and he always fails.
And then this other woman,
Maryland Schlitz,
she also tried to replicate it and she was able to replicate some of it.
So there may be an experimenter bias.
It's not clear if it's the skeptics that are biased or the believers that are
biased.
But in that case,
it's best to just say,
you know,
we don't know it.
So the default position,
the null hypothesis is that it's not true until you prove otherwise.
And that's uh,
that's a difficult one to prove.
Now if they say,
if I say,
well,
why is the effects so subtle?
Why can't you,
you go to Vegas and become a millionaire gambling or play the stock market.
You know,
we know traders just need a tiny,
you know,
one point 0.01% advantage over the other traders or whatever.
And they can make a lot of times it just psychic ability.
Yeah.
So if the psychic ability is a very broad term,
right?
It's almost like saying drugs because like yeah,
there are certain drugs that put you to sleep and certain drugs that make you
hyper,
they are very different effects.
So saying psychic ability like maybe have the ability to see if someone's
looking at you but you don't have the ability to pick the lottery.
Right.
Uh,
so the hard part in testing psych exist to pin down what exactly are you saying
you could do and that that's where it gets pretty fuzzy.
So these like why is it legal for the phone?
Psychics cause that you can't pin them down.
If somebody says,
look,
I'm just giving relationship advice,
why is that illegal?
If I say like the Tony Robbins Netflix documentary,
I'm not your guru,
which is basically I am your guru.
He has that moment in this huge auditorium.
There's like 3000 people there and he gets this woman up on stage and she's got
relationship problems.
He says,
do you have your phone?
She goes,
yeah,
take out your phone and call him right now.
And she,
he talks her through dumping this guy onstage on the phone and he's at work or
something and he's like,
what?
And then she hangs up and everybody's happy that she did this.
Now is that a good thing or a bad thing?
I have no idea.
It's great for show business,
but what have,
you know,
so how the fuck,
I mean that seems crazy.
Like how do you know what kind of relationship they really have now?
Somebody that talked to both of them,
right?
Wouldn't you somebody that,
I brought this up at a,
at an event recently,
a party and somebody said,
oh,
I know the backstory.
His staff had been working in the audience and they,
they knew all about her and the relationship and it was about to go sour anyway.
So we brought her up.
It's like,
okay,
so this is the thing with you see the psychics on TV,
there's a lot of stuff you don't see.
They work the audience,
they know people fill out.
I like the psych,
the faith healers.
They fill out prayer cards,
they put their name and address and their ailment.
And then,
you know,
the faith healers have a little earbud in there and they're listening to the
person in the back reading,
okay,
here's the person they have,
you know,
clock coma or whatever,
and you hear him calling this out.
So,
uh,
so there's a lot of that that we don't see.